okay now I want to remind you uh indices
there's a whole bunch of different names
that all talk about the same thing and
they all kind of have their own
advantages the different names okay
so let me introduce them to you there's
indices right this is plural
what's the singular index index yeah
exactly right so the singular is index
from which we get index notation okay
another word which means exactly the
same thing is exponents now you like you
hardly ever hear that word though it's
it's where we get the phrase expert
another word exponential from it's like
ah it's growing exponentially it has to
do with these right so it's like
exponential that's about when something
is growing super crazy fast right and
also another word which we get from that
is elephant you know how for adding
right it's addition and for subtracting
it's subtraction and for dividing its
its division and for multiplying it's
multiplication right we'll fought for
indices its its exponentiation it sounds
like um it sounds like okay expedition
exp and TI a tion exponentiation like
that rules of it does sound like one
more word indices exponents same thing
one more with the neat saving its powers
okay now power I let that to last
because when you see index notation okay
we often talk about the power and the
corresponding power which is the base so
for example
so quick example right when you see -
cute right - cube get out another color
right but number down the bottom which
is being multiplied over and over again
let's actually write it out it's 2 times
2 times 2 right the 2 is that base right
that's the base there that nobody gets
multiplied repeatedly and the number of
times you do it that's the power yeah
that's exactly right so we would say
that's 2 to the power of 3 on to the
power 4 5 or whatever other number you'd
like okay so you can see each of these
words has its own place I could easily
say I'll look there's the index right or
if you like you know to cube times
look there are indices or those are
exponents or it's all interchangeable
language okay so that's all I'm trying
to get across